Okay, let's see how you did. We have negative 4 squared. Well, negative 4
squared, since the negative is not inside any parentheses, means it's not part
of the base. So, this is going to be negative 1 times 4 squared, and then we
have negative 1. 4 squared, I know is 4 times 4. 4 times 4 is 16, so I have
negative 1 times 16, give me -16. Okay let's try number 2. This time I have the
negative inside the parenthesis, so that means my base is megative 3. So this
ones going to be negative 3 squared, which is -3 times -3. And we know -3 times
-3 gives us a positive 9. Now the 1st 2 problems had even exponents, let's try
these 2 with odd exponents. The 1st problem I have -2 cubed, which means -1
times 2 cubed. -1 times 2 cubed is -1 times 2 times 2 times 2, and 2 times 2
times 2 is 8, so I have negative 1 times 8, which is going to give me negative
8. OK, number four. This time, like in number two, I have the negative 3 in
parentheses, which means it's part of our base. So, negative 3 cubed is just
negative 3 times negative 3 Times negative 3. Negative 3 times negative 3 is
positive 9, positive 9 times negative 3 is negative 27. If I look at number 2
and number 4, I have a negative number as the base. In number 2, if you notice
the exponent here is even. When we raise a negative number to an even power the
answer is going to be positive. And number 4 we have a negative number being
raised to an odd power. Whenever we raise negative numbers to an odd power, the
answer is going to be negative. It's something you can keep in mind. For number
5, notice we have a negative exponent. We know if we have a negative exponent we
have to take the reciprocal of base, so 5 to the negative 2 is 5 over 1 to the
negative 2 because we can rewrite 5 as 5 over 1 and when we take the reciprocal
that's the negative one fifth and we get rid off the negative once we take that
reciprocal of the base, notice once I take the reciprocal I get rid of the
negative exponent. So we have 1/5 squared, which is 1/5 times 1/ 5. And that's
going to be 1 times 1 is 1. And 5 times 5 is 25. So, 5 to the negative 2 is
1/25. Think about how you did. How many did you get right and wrong? Decide if
you need to go back and review the material again, before moving on to the next
section.